PROFESSOR: So it's time to
examine uncountable sets.
And that's what we're going
to do in this segment.
So Cantor's question was,
are all sets the same size?
And he gives a
definitive answer of no.
Cantor's theorem, which
we're about the present,
will show that, in fact, there
isn't any biggest infinity.
For any given infinity,
you can find a bigger one
in a very simple way.
But let's begin by coming
up with the simplest
form of Cantor's
diagonal argument,
of how do you prove that
a set is not countable?
Remember, a set is countable
if you can list it,
possibly with repeats.
So A is countable if there is
a sequence, a0, a1, a2, such
that every element
in the set A shows
up at some time or other in the
list, possibly more than once.
And the only things in the
list are elements of A.
And we saw as an example
that the finite bit strings,
the finite strings
of zeroes and ones,
with the finite
binary words, are
an example of a countable set.
And we claimed last
time, and now we're
about to prove that
the difference is
that if you look at the infinite
bit strings-- One-way infinite.
They have a beginning, and
they go on infinitely right.
The notation being
0, 1 to the omega,
where omega is an indication
of one of the symbols
for a kind of infinity.
And this is going to be an
example of an uncountable set.
How are we going to prove that?
Well, the setup for
using a diagonal argument
is to think about
drawing a matrix.
Suppose that I have
some way of enumerating
the infinite binary sequences,
the 0, 1 to the omega.
So there's a sequence s0,
there's a sequence s1,
there's a sequence s2.
Let's lay them out as though
they were the rows of a matrix.
So s0 is this infinite
binary sequence, 0, 0; 1, 0;
and so on.
And the column labels are simply
the coordinate labels for s0.
So this s0, 0; s0, 1; and so on.
s1 is the next infinite
binary sequence
in this hypothetical list.
And it starts 0, 1, 1, 0,
and goes on, and so on,
down the line.
So the row labels are this
numeration of binary sequences.
And the column labels
are coordinate labels.
And this is a matrix that's
infinite to the right
an infinite down.
But it definitely has
an upper left corner.
So the trick is to try to
find an infinite binary
sequence that is
not in this list,
that it differs from every row.
If I can do that,
then I've shown
that any attempt
to enumerate all
of the binary sequences in 0,
1 to the omega-- any sequence
like s0, s1, s2 of
binary sequences
is missing something, which
means you can't really list it.
Well, how do you find a
sequence that's not here?
Well, pretty easy.
You look at the first digit.
And that was a 0.
So you choose the first
digit of the new sequence
to be 1, the opposite of 0.
You choose the
second digit to be
the opposite of the
coordinate of a digit 1 of s1,
and complement that.
Now here, the digit
2 of S2 is a 0.
So let's make that a 1.
And the next one of the
diagonal is a 0, and so on.
We're going to complement all
of the bits along this diagonal.
So I get a diagonal sequence.
That's why this argument is
called the diagonal argument.
Well, let's think about
this diagonal sequence.
It just goes on, right down
the diagonal of this two
dimensional infinite matrix.
What we can say about it is
that it differs from every row.
Why is that?
Well, it differs from the
15th row at the 15th position,
or coordinate 15.
It differs from the 99th
row at coordinate 99.
It's not in the matrix.
It's not a row of any matrix.
And that immediately
tells you it's over.
Any attempt to list all of the
elements in 0, 1 to the omega
is going to omit a
diagonal element.
It's not possible
to list all of them.
In other words, there
isn't any surjection
from the non-negative
integers to 0, 1 to the omega,
because I've just shown
you how, if you give me
a surjection onto binary
sequences, in effect,
I'm giving you with N a 0
sequence, a first sequence,
a second sequence, and so on.
Then I know exactly how to find
something that's not there.
There can't be a surjection
from N to 0, 1 to the omega.
It's just not true.
And that's why we can say
that 0, 1 to the omega
is uncountable.
Definition of countable--
or an equivalent formulation
of countable,
remember, is that there
is a surjection from the
non-negative integers
to the set.
Well, there isn't any.
We just proved it.
So N is not surj 0, 1.
By the way, it's also
quite easy to say
that there is a surjection from
the infinite binary sequence
to the non-negative integers.
You could map a binary
sequence to the coordinate
of the first one in it.
And that maps every
infinite binary sequence
to a non-negative integer.
It hits every non-negative
integer lots of times.
I hit five with a
sequence that starts
with four zeros and a one.
The only sequence that
doesn't go anywhere
is the all-zero sequence.
But by the way, if you check
the definition of surj,
it doesn't require that
the function be total.
Surj means that there
is a function that
is a surjection to
N. But there doesn't
have to be greater or
equal one arrow out.
There just has to be less
than or equal to one arrow
out, so it's a function.
But of course, it's
easy enough to make it
total, the all-zero sequence.
Just map it to 0.
So now you have both
the 0 and the sequence
that starts-- Any sequence
that starts with 1
will all map to 0.
OK.
So if we remember
our intuition, surj
is read as greater
than or equal to.
So this tells us that the
infinite binary sequences
are a larger set, at
least as large a set
as the non-negative integers.
And the converse is true.
The non-negative integers
are not at least as large
as the infinite
binary sequences.
So we can really say that
non-negative integers
are strictly smaller than
the set of infinite binary
sequences.
Now, strictly
smaller is in quotes
because, again, we
don't know exactly what
the size of infinite sets is.
All we're doing we,
really, is talking
about properties objections,
bijections, surjections,
injections.
OK.
So let's make an
explicit definition.
I'm going to say that A
strict B means that there
is no surjection from A to
B. So if we read A surjection
B intuitively, as A
greater than or equal to B,
this is saying it's
not true that A
is greater than or equal to
B. Or in ordinary language
and thinking about
sets, if it's not true
that you're greater
than or equal to B,
you must be strictly
less than B.
So that's the motivation
for the word strict.
But remember, we're talking
about infinite sets.
And we can't go around assuming
too many properties of strict
until we've proved them.
One non-trivial
property, by the way,
is I've defined strict
that it's not true
that there is a
surjection from A to B,
but I'm not insisting
that there must
be a surjection from
B to A, which would
be the second companion part.
That is, A is not greater
than or equal to B,
and B is greater than or equal
to A. Turns out, technically,
you can prove that.
If there isn't any
surjection from A to B,
there will be a
surjection from B to A.
But that's using a set theoretic
argument that's not so obvious.
And we don't need it.
So this is the
definition of strict.
A straight B means you cannot
get a surjection from A to B.
And we're intuitively reading
it as A is strictly smaller than
B. And what we've just shown
then is that the non-negative
integers strict
0, 1 to the omega,
the infinite binary sequences.
OK, now Cantor's theorem is
a wonderful generalization
of this.
It's a powerful generalization,
but the proof is pretty much
the same, although it sometimes
looks a little different
as it's written up.
And what Cantor's
theorem says, it's
just beautifully
elegant and simple.
It says simply that the
power set is strictly
better than the set.
A strict power set of
A, for every set A,
even if A is finite.
Because remember, if A is
finite, say A has n elements,
then the power set of
A has 2 the n elements.
And you could check that
even for n equals 0,
n is less than or equal to
the-- n is less than 2 to the n.
0 is less than 2 to
the 0, which is 1.
2 is less than 2 squared,
which is 4, and so on.
So even for finite sets, we
have A strict power set of A.
But the cool thing is that it
works even for infinite sets.
Let's take a look.
It's a diagonal argument again.
But now, I mustn't assume
that A is countable.
I'm not going to assume
that I can really
list the elements of A.
But we'll think about it
as though we could.
Let's think about
this matrix again.
So suppose A is this set of
elements, a, b, s, t, d, e.
I'm scrambling up the
alphabet on purpose,
because I don't want you to get
the idea that we're assuming
that A is countable, that you
can list all the elements of A.
I'm not assuming that.
But I'm just writing out
a sample of elements of A.
And let's suppose
that I was trying
to get a surjection from
A to the power set of A.
So suppose I have a
function f that maps each
of the successive elements of A
to some subset of A. So f of a
is part of the power set.
It's a subset of capital A. f
of b is a subset of capital A,
and so on.
And suppose I had
a setup like this.
I'm going to draw a matrix that
looks like the diagonal matrix.
And we're going to extract a
diagonal set and discover that
that diagonal set is
not one of the f's.
It's not f of anything,
which means that f is not
going to be a surjection.
So let's look at it again.
So here's this matrix,
where I'm labeling
the columns of the matrix
by the elements of A.
No particular order here, but
in order to draw a matrix,
I have to write them
down in some order.
And likewise, the
first row is going
to be f of this element a.
Well, what is in
f of A? f of A is
going to be a set of elements.
So let's just write
the elements in f
of A down, under the
corresponding column label.
So here's an example, where
f of A has an a and no b,
and has it has an s
in it, no c, no d.
It has an e.
Likewise, f of b has an
a and b, and no s or t,
but it's got a c, and so on.
So I filled in this
matrix by taking
f of an element in A, which is
supposed to be a subset of A,
and writing out all of the
elements in that subset,
under the corresponding
element of the subset.
So a b goes under a b if it's
in f of c, and s goes under an s
if it's in f of c.
Nothing goes under a t
if t is not in f of C.
And that's what
we're seeing here.
So I'm laying out
as though I was
using 0's and 1's for an
infinite binary sequence.
I'm laying out each
of the sets that
are in the range of
f along this row.
And now with this setup,
and I can define a new set,
which is not going to be an f.
How do I get that?
Well, what I'm going
to do is in my new set
I'm not going to have
any of the elements that
appear on the diagonal.
So if a is a member
of f of A, that
means that a appears
in this coordinate,
it's not going to be in my set.
If b is in f of b,
meaning that b appears
in the f of b row
under the column b,
it's not going to be in my set.
On the other hand,
s is not in f of s,
because there's no s there.
So I'm going to put
an s there in magenta.
And likewise, I'm
going to stick elements
in or out the opposite
of whether they
appear on the diagonal.
And this is going to
give me a set D, which
is going to be my diagonal set.
So if we write this
out, what we're
saying is suppose that
I have a function f
from A to the power set of
A. Then what I'm going to do
is define a subset of A
that's not in the range of f,
namely set D, which is
the set of those elements
in A, such that little
a is not an f of a.
Namely, if an element
appeared on the diagonal
because an element with column
label A was in the row f of a,
then I left that out of my set.
And if it was not in that
location in the matrix,
I put it in my set.
So I'm keeping all
the elements that
aren't on the diagonal,
that's my diagonal set D.
And what I know about it is
that D is not in the range of f,
because it differs from every
possible row of the matrix.
If the row is labeled
with f of a as f of a,
then it differs in the column
a, f of a from that row.
And therefore, my set D is
not a row of this matrix.
And that means that it's
not equal to f of anything.
So I've just found that there
is no f arrow into D. D's not
in the range of f.
That means that if I had such an
f from A to the power set of A,
it's not a surjection,
because D is always left out.
So f is not a surjection.
And since, you know, f
is any function from A
to the power set of A, none
of them are surjections,
and that means there is no
surjection from A to the power
set of A. In other words,
A strict power set of A.
There is no surjection.
Now, a special case
of this, of course,
is that the non-negative
integers are strictly
smaller than the power
set of N. Of course,
that's just an instance
of Cantor's theorem.
We're applying A being the
set of non-negative integers.
So there is no surjection
from the non-negative integers
to the subsets of
non-negative integers.
Again, that means that
the power set of N
is an example of
an uncountable set,
because the definition
of countable
is that there would
be a surjection from N
to power set of N. We're
saying there isn't any,
so it's not countable.
Not countable is usually
phrased as uncountable.
So the power set of N is
maybe our second example
of an uncountable
set, the first one
being the infinite
sequences of binary numbers.
Now as a matter of fact,
just as we had a general way
to prove countability-- you can
show that a set is countable
if there is a surjection
from a set you
know is countable
onto the target,
then the target's countable.
Take the contrapositive
of that lemma,
and you can say that if
a set A is uncountable
and there is a
surjection from C to A,
then C has to be uncountable.
That's just the contrapositive
of the previous one.
If C was countable, then
A would be countable.
So if A is uncountable,
C must be uncountable.
So this gives us, again,
a nice general way
to prove uncountability
of sets, once I
have a couple in my repertoire.
Well, it means that
we could have deduced
that 0, 1 to the omega, that the
infinite binary sequences were
uncountable, because
we know that there's is
a bijection between the
infinite binary sequences
and the power set of N.
We described that bijection
without knowing anything
about any other properties of
the infinite binary sequences
in the power set of N, whether
they were countable or not.
But now that Cantor's
theorem tells us
that the power set
of N is uncountable
and there's a bijection,
the previous lemma says,
in particular, there's a
surjection from 0, 1 to omega
to the power set of N, which
means 0, 1 to the omega
is uncountable.
So what I'm illustrating then
is that the proof that we used
directly by a diagonal
argument to figure out
that 0, 1 to the
omega was uncountable,
it's really a special
case of the more general
diagonal argument that we used
to prove Cantor's theorem.
And we get that
0, 1 to the omega
is uncountable as a
consequence of Cantor's theorem
about the power set of N. And
so we've got two different ways
then to prove that the
infinite binary sequences are
uncountable.
Another example
of an uncountable
set, it's the real numbers.
And they're a cute example.
Remember, we saw that
the rational numbers
were countable.
The real numbers
are uncountable.
Well, how do I prove that?
I'm just going to
show you a surjection
from the real numbers onto
the infinite binary sequences.
How am I going to do that?
Well, it's a kind of
stupid trick, but it works.
I'm using both positive
and negative reals.
So let's look at
some real number,
and look at its
binary representation,
so for the moment
that it's positive.
So let's look at, say,
the binary representation
of some number, like 3 and 1/3.
So that means that
if we're thinking
of these as binary places,
this is the 0's place,
the 2's place, the 4's place.
This is half's place,
the quarter's place,
the eighth's place.
Then the binary representation
of 3 and 1/3 would be 2.
And then this infinite
repeating-- not decimal,
but [? bicipal-- ?]
binary expansion, 010101.
And we will examine how I
know that that's a third.
But take it for
granted that that's
what you get as the
repeated fraction.
You could figure that out
by just doing division of 1
by 3 in binary.
Anyway, just as there's
a decimal expansion
of every real number, there's
a binary expansion just using
base 2.
So here's the binary
expansion of 3 and 1/3.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to map 3 and 1/3 to
this binary sequence.
I'm going to ignore
the decimal place.
Binary is not decimal place.
It's a [? becimal ?]
place, or binary position.
And I'm just going to
take this to mapping
the sequence, 11010101.
And I claim that
this is a surjection
because you're going to
hit every possible binary
sequence in this way.
Well, almost.
Let's take a closer look.
There's a problem with mapping
to things that start with 0,
because let's examine
that a half is 0.10000000.
So I would map it to that.
And it will end.
But there's an ambiguity,
because a half is also equal
to 0.011111, just as 0.999999
is equal to 1.000000 in decimal,
you get the same infinite
carry issue here in binary.
So numbers that end in
all ones have another way
to represent the very same
number by a sequence that
ends in all zeroes.
So how am I going
to hit-- if I'm
using up a half to hit this one,
what's left to hit that one?
Oh, how about using minus 1/2?
It's there, and
that's part of R,
so I'm just going to
map the negative numbers
to the version of the
expansion that starts with 0
and has an infinite
number of ones.
And the positive one that
ends with an infinite number
of zeroes.
And otherwise, I'm going
to map plus and minus
numbers to the same place.
So this is going to give me
the needed surjection from R
to the infinite
binary sequences.
And by our previous lemma,
that implies, sure enough,
that the real numbers
are uncountable.